author Fergus board awake in his book
bound for Canon he covers sixty years of
the Underground Railroad this one-hour
event was hosted by borders books in
Silver Spring Maryland as I'm sure
you've heard a couple of times now we
have authors Burgas border with us he's
a journalist historian and scholar his
riveting book includes famous figures
such as Harriet Tubman Frederick
Douglass John Brown and Josiah Henson as
well as myriad hitherto obscure heroes
heroines and villains
he's also the author of cafe a journey
in search of all China killing the white
man's Indians of reinvention of Native
Americans and my mother's ghost a
courageous woman a son's love and the
power of memory he's written for the New
York Times
Smithsonian magazine the Atlantic
Monthly and Reader's Digest mr. bored
awake reveals that the true story of the
Underground Railroad is a much more
morally complex and politically divisive
than even the myth suggest against a
backdrop of the country's westward
expansion arose a fierce class of clash
of values that was a war for the
country's soul not since the American
Revolution had Americans engaged in an
act of such vast and profound civil
disobedience that not only challenged
prevailing mores but also subverted
federal law freeing slaves is against
the law but those persecuted Patriots
chose justice for all
and we invite you to come in and have a
seat and listen to the story from bound
from Canaan the stories of real men and
women like David Ruggles who invented
the black underground in New York City
bold Quakers like Isaac hopper and Levi
coffin who risked their lives to build
the Underground Railroad
and the inimitable Harriet Tubman who
all show how the Underground Railroad
gave birth to this country's first
racially integrated religiously inspired
movement for social change we welcomed
this author to borders Silver Spring
tonight and invite everyone to get their
coffee autograph when he's finished with
his presentation thank you well thanks
and and thanks to everyone one who's
here tonight as you'll probably gather
once I once I get get rolling here I
love talking about the people I've
written about in this book and this is a
book it's a piece of American history
that's just rich with stories and and
and significance that have often been
neglected in the past I'm gonna start
just by reading a short piece which
happens to be the first few pages of the
book and it's kind of self-explanatory I
think basically this is a a snapshot of
the Underground Railroad in action
the year is 1844 or 1845 imagine the
scene the night air is accurate as it
always is in Madison Indiana with the
smell of the slaughterhouses and
tanneries that line the North Shore of
the Ohio River it is almost 10 o'clock
and in this era before electricity and
street lamps the darkness is profound
the barber has done what he was told he
is alone on the street corner he waits
with the nearly killing anxiety of a man
who is about to commit a crime he is the
slave and is about to steal himself the
barber had been working in Madison and
sending his earnings back to his master
in Kentucky a common enough arrangement
in the border states he could walk away
from the corner he knew he could go home
abandon hope of escape get along somehow
as a slave and stay safe in a way but he
could not forget George de baptists
words to him aren't you ashamed you a
man able to make money and
care of yourself but the good trade
young strong and a man all over if you
were only a mind to be to be calling
another man your master like a dog
paying over to him your wages at ten
o'clock steps approach and a black man
slips from the shadows he tells the
barber to walk to the roadbed where the
new railway is to be laid north from
Madison when he gets to it he is to walk
north until he reaches the post that
marks the second mile and then whistle
twice the barber follows the
instructions he is leaving an entire
life behind and walking into the unknown
he is attuned to every rustle click and
murmur of life in the night straining
for the sounds of feet in pursuit it's a
hard place for blacks the southern edge
of Indiana white vigilantes sometimes
attack people in their homes in Madison
slave catchers prowl the back country
hunting Runaways the barber knows as
every fugitive knows that at any moment
his break for freedom may turn into a
disaster at the two mile marker the
barber screws up his courage and
whistles another black man slips from
the woods with a gun at the ready walk
another two miles he tells the barber
and falls into step behind him at the
next appointed spot a second armed man
appears and orders him to walk two more
miles with the two gunmen now following
behind him the drill is repeated four
times until the barber is surrounded by
eight armed men sixteen miles beyond
Madison instead of another gunman
there's a wagon waiting into it the
barber climbs and for the first time
during that long night perhaps he begins
to breathe normally again ahead of him
live the welcoming farms of White
Presbyterian and Quaker farmers of free
blacks who do not fear the writs and
guns of slave hunters and his own
freedom
George des Baptist the man who prompted
the barbers elaborate escape who
executed it who ensured that even if the
fugitives party was discovered it was
carrying enough firepower to defend
itself was also as it happened to barber
he was also the Sikh
head of the local Underground Railroad
in some respects des Baptist was a very
ordinary man about 30 years old at the
time well known to everyone in Madison
he was a respectable member of the
town's small free bout black middle
class but unknown to them almost every
day of his life he tested the limits to
which a black man would be allowed to go
in the deeply racist America of the
1840s it was dangerous enough for
radical white abolitionists to risk
helping fugitive strangers breaking
federal law every time they get it for a
black man who could never count on the
law to be on his side it was brave
beyond imagining for the Underground
both opportunity and death were as close
as the Kentucky shore madison stood on
the invisible line that ran along the
ohio river dividing the slave states
from the free as absolutely as if they
have been cut apart by a cleaver during
his eight years in madison de baptist
estimated that he personally assisted
108 fugitives to freedom and several
times that number indirectly failure at
any point could easily have cost in his
life
the name of the barber who escaped that
night more than a century and a half ago
has long been forgotten his story still
exists only because it survived in the
memory of George des Baptist or
recounted it to a reporter for a Detroit
newspaper in 1870 a few years before he
died but the events of that night were
epical in their way another chip had
silently been knocked out of the edifice
of slavery and another victory gained
for the clandestine army that was
changing America so Georgia Baptist by
the way the man who organized that
escape was one of the just the most
remarkable people I've ever come to know
and it's impossible of course to step
into the shoes of somebody who lived a
century and a half ago much less
somebody coming from a part of society
that's so unlike what we live in today
but
Georgia Baptist went on from this two
years later he was he fled from Madison
he was exposed he would have been
murdered if he remained the underground
in Madison was temporarily broken up
Georgia Baptist went on to Detroit where
he helped create one of the most
efficient underground operations in the
country in Detroit and and went on to
thrive and prosper and in fact became
one of the most prosperous businessmen
in Detroit while working with the
underground but I want to tell you a
little bit about the book and then and
then if time doesn't get the better of
me I'm gonna read another selection
later on bound for Canaan is a narrative
history of the Underground Railroad from
its beginnings in Philadelphia in the
1790s up to the Civil War it's not an
encyclopedic survey of the Underground
what I mean is it's not a catalogue of
every person who might have been
involved or every house that might have
been part of it or every line that was
part of the Underground Railroad rather
I tried to show in this book how the
Underground came into being how it
operated and more than anything else
what kind of people black and white and
men and women made it work and I've also
tried to show throughout that the
Underground Railroad was much more than
the picturesque legend that we usually
think of but rather that it was a
movement with genuinely far-reaching
political and moral consequences that
changed relations between the races in
ways more radical than anything that
would be seen again until the second
half of the 20th century what was the
Underground Railroad like I it was I
think if the Underground were coming
into being today it would probably use
the language of the modern internet
that's to say it was a diverse flexible
interlocking efficient system with
really no central control
we call it the Underground Railroad
because even though it began as far back
as the 1790s as I said and was
well underway by the 1830s its period of
greatest expansion was from the 1830s of
the 1850s which was exactly
contemporaneous with the development of
iron railroads around the United States
and the language of iron railroads lent
itself perfectly to what the Underground
was already doing which is to say
speaking of stations for safe houses and
passengers for fugitives and lines for
the roads that were followed and and
trains for farm wagons and engines for
teams of horses and so on and so on in
all I've estimated conservatively I
think that the underground probably
assisted in all approximately a hundred
thousand fugitives to freedom between
1800 and 1860 as I said I think that's a
conservative figure nobody was clocking
in fugitives as they reached Detroit or
Buffalo or anywhere else but local
numbers were often recorded many many
underground railroad groups particularly
in cities actually were proud of the
number they had assisted in a given year
so there's we're there really more
numbers out there than I think a lot of
people imagine there are the Underground
was a model of democracy in action it
operated with a maximum of grassroots
involvement in fact it was really the
first grassroots political movement in
American history
an underground stationmaster from Ohio a
gentleman and Isaac Beck whom I've
written about and here put it this way
which I like there was no regular
organization no Constitution no officers
no laws or agreement or rule except the
Golden Rule every man did what seemed
right in his own eyes
from its beginning in Philadelphia the
Underground was a collaborative movement
involving free blacks anti-slavery
whites and slaves and slaves underscore
that because they think the real
forgotten or unknown heroes of the
Underground Railroad and the people
whose stories are really hardest to get
at are those individuals who were
enslaved in the south but chose to
remain in slavery they made a moral
courageous moral decision to remain in
slavery so that they could help other
people out and there's one man I
mentioned in here who in that capacity
worked at North Carolina for close to 20
years before he himself finally did
leave and there's another man Arnold
Gregg stand história is is a little
clearer because he was a very young man
when he joined the underground in 1859
and lived a long life and gave an
interview much later who did the same
kind of work in Kentucky
most of those individuals are forgotten
they were exposed caught they never made
it out I've estimated also that the
Underground may have included by the
1850s something like 10 or 15 thousand
participants and that is a careful
conservative educated guess and it
includes not just the people you usually
think of that's to say conductors and
station masters but also people like
preachers and Teamsters and peddlers who
carried information about the
underground into the upper South sailors
and ships stewards who helped people
flee help Runaways flee on vessels and
to a degree people like the wider pool
of family members friends fellow
parishioners who although they might
never engage in illegal activity
protected those who did and made it
possible for them to do their work who
made it possible for the people doing
the most dangerous most illegal work
really for the most part to remain and
shrouded in secrecy
apart from sporadic slave rebellions and
the countless individual acts of
defiance by individual slaves against
masters
many of which we know many more of which
we don't know only the Underground
Railroad
physically resisted the repressive laws
that held slaves in bondage as the
country's first great movement of mass
civil disobedience since the American
Revolution it was also the country's
first interracial political movement it
was also the first American mass
movement that asserted the principle of
personal active responsibility for other
people's human rights in addition the
Underground Railroad in the broader
abolition movement that of course it was
part of was the seedbed of American
feminism Elizabeth Cady Stanton whose
name you you all know of course as the
first national leader of the women's
movement said the following woman is
more fully identified with the slave
than man can possibly be the the women
who organized the Seneca Falls
conference in 1848 that the first
women's rights conference were all women
of the Underground Railroad in the
Underground Railroad women were for the
first time participants in a political
movement on an equal plane with men
sheltering and clothing fugitive slaves
although they're often dropped out of
the stories who was doing that work it
was the wives and the sisters and the
daughters they served as guides they
served as conductors Harriet Tubman
whose name we all know was heroic beyond
belief but there were a lot of people
men and women of course in black and
white doing this but she wasn't the only
woman women also of course risk reprisal
against their families and they publicly
insisted more and more loudly that their
voices be heard along with their men
folks someone asked me before I began
how I got involved in this while I'm
writing about the Underground Railroad
I'll tell you briefly part of the answer
is that I grew up in a neighborhood in
New York State that was next to a
community that was said to have been
founded by fugitives who came north on
the Underground Railroad and the story
was part of the the local lore that I
grew up with
and those those those people those
supposed founders were often cited as
proof of the power of individuals to
defy injustice and to shape the world
they lived in for the better now in the
interest of truth and packaging I'm
gonna tell you I researched that when I
was started working my book and I found
that that story is sadly not true
the neighborhood wasn't founded until
the 20th century and there are many many
Underground Railroad legends like this
all over our country but nonetheless it
became part of the warp and woof of my
own childhood and way of thinking about
people in about the Underground Railroad
in a in another sense this this began on
a June day in 1998 and I stood in
southern Ontario to a place called the
dawn Institute that's a sight it doesn't
exist anymore actually which was a
school and a refuge for fugitive slaves
founded in 1841 by a man named Josiah
Henson now I will say I was there
working for a national magazine my
editor at the time Phil Beeman is here
and it's really a pleasure to have Bill
here because we worked on this together
back in 1998 Josiah Henson was a
fugitive slave who was enslaved
literally right down the road in
Rockville and the slave quarters that he
lived in stand today they're part of a
private home it's not a visible place
but it's there you know just just as
stone's throw from where we're sitting
Josiah Henson Oh continued in slavery in
in in Kentucky later in life he became
one of the models for Harriet Beecher
Stowe's Uncle Tom of Uncle Tom's Cabin
but this man was nothing like the
stereotype that we've all received he
was a bold tough physical giant and
extremely intelligent not to say
brilliant man and a very skilled manager
he was indeed the manager of the farm on
which he worked and in fact
was an overseer a fact which he was not
very happy about later in life when he
wrote his own memoir who in 1831 fled
from slavery in Kentucky near Owensboro
Kentucky with his family he carried two
small boys on his back in a homemade
knapsack and walked with them through
what was then the frontier of Indiana
and Ohio all the way to Canada left one
son behind and they couldn't get him
away that night and practically every
fugitive left somebody like that behind
it could have whether it's a child a
parent a brother a sister a wife a
husband and no other Americans really
have had to make that that decision
between freedom and family you know and
I think that too is an element of what
people who came north via the
underground went through that we often
perhaps don't adequately acknowledge I
mean what people were carrying with them
regardless of how many pairs of socks
they had so to speak you know what they
were what kind of pain they were
carrying with them because of who they
had to leave behind anyway standing at
the site of the dawn Institute in Canada
it's very beautiful place it's a kind of
fertile plain looking out across this
this bucolic Canadian landscape this was
a terminus of the Underground Railroad
by the way Henson the fugitive
established a school there to educate
people who came north and a few other
fugitives and to help assimilate people
to life in a free society how do you use
money how do you earn a salary
what's a mortgage things like that and I
found myself asking you know who were
these people you know you know starting
to conjure them up in my imagination and
what had driven them to risk death by
fleeing and who had they left behind and
how had they gotten there and who'd
helped them and those questions were the
ones that began this book and in a way
I've I followed them throughout this
this narrative and I have the narrative
of the Underground Railroad is
primarily the interwoven stories of
people let's say there were some myths
about the underground Briella that were
necessary to push through to get at the
reality as I said practically any
community in the North certainly has a
house or a cave or a basement we're
fugitive slaves who were supposedly
sheltered now I live in the Hudson
Valley Inn in upstate New York about 40
miles south of the city of Albany and in
my community there are so it said
tunnels we're fugitive slaves were
hidden before the civil war and when I
was working on this book people were
calling me saying you're gonna write
about the tunnels right you know when
you do the tunnels will you take me down
and well you know I was really
distressed to have to disabuse people by
telling them that these tunnels a lot
less romantically were really just cold
coal storage areas and primarily date
from the 20th century and that
historically in the antebellum area that
region of the mid-hudson was the the
largest slave holding area in the north
we had slavery in all states to some
degree until about 1827 with the
exception of Vermont and the region also
was a an antebellum democratic party's
stronghold we all know that Democratic
Party then was tied to the slaveholding
south and frankly the town I lived in is
probably one of the last places a
fugitive in his right mind would go to
hide as I said the Underground is about
a lot more than bricks and mortar and
sometimes I think we tend to get hung up
on places on was this a hiding place or
was that a hiding place or wasn't it and
really the Underground the great
importance of the Underground I think
lies in what people did people I find
people whom I write about here I found
startlingly modern and peculiarly
archaic at the same time combining
really radical ideas about race and
political action with very traditional
not to say very conservative ideas of
personal honor and sacred duty and
should bear in mind that both the
Underground Railroad and the larger
abolition movement grew out of the
evangelical revival of the early 19th
century most people were were carried
with them a spiritual imperative to do
what they were doing which was what led
them away from a kind of complacent
acceptance of slavery and for many of
the people who were the the most
courageous participants in the
Underground I think what they were they
they saw and felt what they were doing
as a kind of prayer in action it's not
true of everybody but it was certainly
true of a lot of people there is a
distinction here between white activists
and black activists wine activists
really had to think their way out of
slate away from slavery and kind of find
a way of explaining to themselves why
slavery was sinful and immoral and evil
frankly african-americans didn't have to
go through that process you know Minh
you read the literature written by black
veterans at the underground they're not
kind of debating with each other why
slavery is bad you know that's kind of
the starting point but it's important
it's important to the reality the
underground that these two streams that
people came together and they created
the first I think truly free zone of
action in American public and political
life where people could begin to
function on an equal plane lots of
abolitionists were racists in today's
terms they were enemies of slavery they
made tremendous sacrifices to help
fugitives but frankly they weren't very
comfortable with black
and this is part of the explanation I
think for what happened after the Civil
War a lot of people walked away from the
consequences of terminating slavery not
everybody did some some like Levi coffin
who's a man i-i've write about a great
length in the book of Quaker began doing
underground work in North Carolina in
1819 continued right up to the Civil War
and did did find work during the Civil
War and afterward working with freedmen
one oh that one other myth of a sort
that I want to mention is the under
grants secrecy we call it the
Underground Railroad but except when it
wasn't you know what what do I mean
really of course in the upper south it
was as secret as it could possibly be it
was a life-and-death business in the
upper south and I keep saying upper
south because very very few fugitives
ever got out of the deep south the vast
majority came from three states Kentucky
Virginia which was then a border state
there was no West Virginia in Antebellum
times in Maryland those three states the
vast majority the Underground was
comparatively secret along the border
that's to say along the Ohio River the
Pennsylvania Maryland line but in fact
the mat slave master slave hunters often
knew who was really doing the work in
towns like Ripley Ohio or Madison
Indiana Georgia Baptist I mentioned
earlier had to flee he was exposed
southern Pennsylvania if you read the
documents left by activists in southern
Pennsylvania slave Raiders are riding up
every now and again demanding to be let
into the house the the the the the
hunters knew more often than we imagine
who really was doing this work so it
took brilliant management for four
members of the underground really to to
keep their passengers safe and
that they succeeded by and the vast
majority of times as a testament to how
effective they were but as you went
further north the underground was
amazingly open abolitionist newspapers
like the voice of the fugitive this is a
great paper it's in some archives it was
created and edited by a fugitive named
Henry Bibb who based it in Sandwich
Ontario he's a great newspaper man and
it reads fine today you would have to
library of an hour to kill and if you
can find voice of the fugitive you'll
have a great read anyway he often
reported underground news in detail
including the passage of fugitives
through town and even the names of
people who helped them in other places
for example Albany New York and Detroit
the Underground published posters
announcing what it was doing and how
many fugitives had helped and one man I
I've written about and here a length it
was one of my favorite favorite people
whom I encountered as a man named
Jermaine Logan he was enslaved in
Tennessee and rode boldly on horseback
with a friend from Tennessee to Ontario
and in Tennessee in Kentucky he
succeeded masquerading as a freed black
man and he went went up to the front
doors of white homesteads and knocked on
the door and offered to pay for place to
stay and he got away with it most of the
time he also was obliged to fight his
way through gangs of patrollers who as I
suspect you know were basically gangs of
armed thugs whose job it was to ensure
that African Americans slaved or free
were not in the wrong place and punished
them with impunity anyway I won't get
sidetracked into Logan's story but he
eventually went to college in upstate
New York the Oneida Institute became a
minister an abolitionist leader and
eventually the leader of the underground
in the city of Syracuse New York
central New York state by the mid 1850s
he was advertising his home in
newspapers as the unn
grande station in Syracuse he also had
business cards and I've seen these in
Syracuse I'm not making this up
it said says Germaine Logan station
master underground railroad he handed
him out there were public fundraisers
for the Syracuse underground held in the
city council chambers and a local band
even composed a popular song called the
Underground Railroad quickstep I tried
to picture this night failed and
dedicated it to Jermaine Logan in my
book there's also a poster that appeared
in Detroit on April 19th 1853 and it
reads in bold letters stockholders of
the underground railroad company hold on
to your stock the market has an upward
tendency by the Express train which
arrived this morning at 3 o'clock
$15,000 worth of human merchandise
consisting of 29 able-bodied men and
women fresh and sound from the Carolina
and Kentucky plantations have arrived
safe with the Depot on the other side
stockholders don't forget the meeting at
2 o'clock at the ferry you want to find
the Underground Railroad it's at the
ferry so I mean these days I'm giving
you these examples as proof of how the
underground and more broadly the
abolitionist movement did change the
hearts minds and ultimately the soul of
Americans in the north and and made the
underground and brought the underground
above-ground now ok I I hadn't mind to
read another short section which I'd
like to do but I hope that's okay with
everybody let's say
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna make it a short
one this is about a gentleman named
David Ruggles who created who organized
the Underground Railroad in New York
City New York City was a slave catchers
paradise New York City was politically
pro-southern because it was economically
tied to the south magistrate's
constables lawyers collaborated in New
York City with slave hunters from the
south they advertised their their slave
catching business in New York newspapers
they were referred to by abolitionists
as the New York slave caching club and
abolitionists were very embattled in New
York City I mean this isn't the New York
City of today believe me but David
Ruggles was a another one of these
remarkable people he was born free in
the state of Connecticut he was well
educated even but scholarly he he wore
glasses looked like today's granny
glasses look like a graduate student
basically and the one image of him that
still survives
but wearing a really rather dramatic
tall white beaver hat and he had been a
teacher in the City of Poughkeepsie New
York briefly and then he came down to
New York City and he came in like a
meteorite into into New York and he
shook up the whole world of abolition
and slave hunting in New York City even
fellow abolitionists weren't quite
prepared for what they got with David
Ruggles he was an extremely bold
confrontational man very articulate I
should say parenthetically he was not
only that but he was also an
intellectual within his time he set up a
reading room for young black men and
women I expect although he says black
men who were simply not permitted in
public otherwise public Reading Room's
and he worked as hard as he could to
lead people to education anyway but here
I'm gonna read an example of how David
David Ruggles operated heat by the way
probably assisted something like 1,000
fugitives in the course of about three
to four years of activity in New York
City from 1835 to 1839 he went blind
finally and he had to retire who he was
he had to retire partly because of his
health partly because he had been a
target of all kinds of persecution he
was his house was broken into he himself
was almost kidnapped and put on a ship
and sent south into slavery and he was
beaten up he was jailed anyway but this
is David Ruggles inaction in June 1838
Ruggles reported in detail how he had
entered the house of DK dodge a slave
holder from South Carolina who
maintained a home on Henry Street in
Brooklyn Heights where he kept three
slaves one of them for four years far
longer than the nine months permitted to
out-of-state slave owners by New York
law at least one of the slaves a
maidservant named charity had made
contact with the vigilance committee and
asked for help once admitted to the
Dodge house
Ruggles simply refused to leave dodges
wife maintained that they had brought
the slaves north specifically to set
them free haven't I told you that you're
free she asked charity you told me to
say so if anybody asked me charity
replied emboldened by Ruggles his
presence but you beat me here much as
ever Missy why if mrs. Dodge brought you
here to be free she would not treat you
ill but on the contrary she would be
kind to you and pay you wages that
Ruggles wages exclaimed charity oh no
said dodge but I take good care of you
at this point a neighbor a doctor
McLennan a little fellow with a pair of
stiffwhiskers suddenly appeared
apparently intending to evict Ruggles
whom he charged with being an intruder
Ruggles retorted that it was the doctor
who is the true intruder with no right
to interfere against liberty and the
laws of the state I'm here to remove a
disorderly person McLennan declare it
declared find such a person here and I
will aid you in his removal replied
Ruggles I was invited here to relieve
humanity I wish you would leave sir
McLennan repeated I wish you would leave
seer said Ruggles you aggravate me said
the doctor you don't aggravate me
replied Ruggles the doctor looking over
and under his spectacles as though
getting ready to use his rattan cane
visibly came to the conclusion Ruggles
supposed that since the abolitionist was
some inches taller and heavier he would
not attempt it after further irritable
debate over the consequences of bringing
slaves into New York the doctor at last
begged Ruggles to wait until the man of
the house returned before attempting to
carry off any of the slaves they are
perfectly free to do as they please said
Ruggles blandly if they choose to remain
they can I employ no force to remove
them if they go with me I'll protect
them I is free as a rat and I'm going
charity proclaimed if I was to stop here
I should find myself dead tomorrow
morning I know you mrs. Buggles
concluded as I was then ready to leave
charity took a bundle of rags which were
an apology for clothes and with the
editor left her kind and affectionate
mistress to take care of herself and is
now doing well too to conclude I I'll
just say that people like David Ruggles
George des Baptist Jermaine Logan and
some of the other people I've mentioned
here were people of a type that really
had not existed amongst
african-americans in the United States
before the Underground Railroad made it
possible outside their black churches
these were these were men who acted in
the political realm these were these
were people who had a sphere where they
could assert themselves and lead others
and indeed as I think I said earlier
many underground in many underground
cells the leadership was in fact black
and whites and white women white men had
no special privilege owing to their
color it varied from place to place in
some areas the underground primarily
black and other places it was primarily
white in many most places there was a
synergy between both groups I think in a
in an era now I'm talking about today
when Americans have a great deal of
difficulty really talking squarely with
each other about the whole subject of
race the Underground Railroad and the
fact that our ancestors a hundred and
fifty years ago were able to function
together to save people's lives and to
create a sphere of freedom together that
I think the Underground Railroad
deserves to be part of every discussion
of race in the country and with that
I'll finish thank you for being patient
short
mr. border WIC will sign copies and if
you have any questions you're welcome to
ask them now as well sure should it
should we take some questions first or
if anybody really wants to go and is
waiting to get a book signed by all
means please yeah
how would you characterize how your work
is being received on this subject oh
it's really been received with a lot of
enthusiasm and interest and I have to
say during the years of research I did I
was just struck over and over by the
atmosphere of cooperation and
collaboration amongst people across the
country who were engaged in digging into
the history of the Underground Railroad
and you know I'm a journalist by
profession I'm skeptical by temperament
and I don't take very much at face value
but over and over I was genuinely
inspired by the caliber of individuals
and I mean across the board regardless
of their backgrounds who were engaged in
the Underground Railroad and the degree
of moral conviction that people brought
to what they did and the kinds of risks
that people took not once or twice but
month after month and year after year on
behalf of strangers and some of that
spirit certainly infuses people who do
historical work or research bearing on
the Underground Railroad and and I I
think as I implied that that that there
are there are a lot of genuine and
profound lessons to be drawn from the
history of the Underground for us in the
present day so that was a long answer to
it to your question but people have been
very enthusiastic about the book
all right
you know I actually can't say no just a
regular house in the lux Manor kind of
older housing affluent housing
development Georgetown I can tell you a
few things about it but uh a very
elderly lady was living there until
recently she died not just within this
past year someone else is living there
at present I do know that the owner very
much hopes that a foundation will
purchase the property and preserve it
historically but I I had been asked by
the historical the Rockville Historical
Society kind of not to give detailed
information because it's a private
property but it is there and you know I
think if you drop by the Rockville
Historical Society and ask politely or
ask this kind lady in the front row so
sort of tell you about where it is and
you could drive by but the slave
quarters are part of the house currently
and they do stand there and it's you
can't go right up to the building
without walking on private property but
it is there hi
sure well as I said as I you know I
tried to address this earlier when I was
speaking that the great majority of
white abolitionists came into
abolitionism as well as into the
temperance movement which was
simultaneous from the great evangelical
revival of the early 19th century I'm
talking about Presbyterians Methodists
and the Northeast Congregationalists
primarily and some other groups the
Quakers are a little different
the Quakers really tend to stick with
with with social issues throughout
although not all Quakers did there was a
split in amongst the Quakers over
political activism as early as 1827 and
another one in the 1850s many Quakers
opposed political action by other
Quakers they felt that contravene they
were there their faith but amongst other
groups as I said underground work was
profoundly I think religious conspiracy
in the underground and what it was about
was erasing the sin of slavery from
America and once slavery had been
terminated the commitment frankly was
not to African Americans but it was to
their own moral growth and let's say to
the moral growth of the country as a
whole and once and it was slavery that
was the sinful stain not the the
conditions under which African Americans
might happen to live it was also in the
mid 19th century and frankly very very
few people understood the kind of work
that needed to be done to help people
move out of the you know the pit of
slavery you know generations of slavery
into being able to you know live kind of
competitive lives in a place like the
United States Canada succeeded at that
now Canadians will say
straight up if he talked in them and
today this Canada can be as racist as
the United States and yes
look our communities were segregated up
to the 1950s - I was just up in Halifax
Nova Nova Scotia talking about this book
and having that conversation but that
said in Canada the law was square the
law was fair the law was on the side of
immigrants and including African
American immigrants and there was no
legal discrimination of any kind in
Canada in the antebellum period blacks
voted right from the start and and I
tell the great story in here actually in
chapter cold laboratories of freedom
about the model communities that were
established by and for fugitive slaves
in southern Ontario and how when a
racist demagogue got elected to
Parliament in Canada you know
race-baiting demagogue of the type we
all knew so well down here two years
later he was voted out because all the
members of the elgyn community every
single resident was registered to vote
may marched on mass down to Chatham in
Ontario and voted and voted the guy out
along with the support of white white
abolitionists up there and the very
first black man elected to office in
Canada Isaac shad elected 1859 was a
former underground railroad station
master from West Chester Pennsylvania
now but your question was really about
what happened here so as I said once
slavery was over that mark the
commitment was going the commitment
wasn't african-americans per se some did
III I intend to write a book in the
future actually about what many of these
people did in in the in the in the
period during the Reconstruction period
and some of them went into the South
white and black
set up schools many of them became
teachers worked with the Freedmen's
Bureau did what we today call social
work and lived very tough courageous
lives even as the South in the United
States as a whole re committed itself to
segregation and institutionalized racism
is that a did I sort of answer your
question Thanks hi
related that you choose discover
anywhere your research
well that's a great question I'm glad
you asked that there's no single story
that applies to Native Americans and the
Underground Railroad another way of
putting it is if you were a fugitive if
we can possibly imagine being a fugitive
fleeing into an area that was inhabited
by an American Indian tribe anything
might happen you might be accepted and
taken into the tribe and protected you
might be given a home you might be fed
like Josiah Henson is a great encounter
on the part of Josiah Henson that was
the man who carried his two sons in the
sack on his back in northern Ohio where
there were still Indians then he and his
family are making their way down this
kind of wilderness road and they run
into some Indians and both of them sort
of jumped back about five steps because
Henson has never seen any Indians and
he's scared out of his wits and the
Indians frankly I've never seen any
black people but the Indians kind of
helped them along and give them some
food send them on their way but there
are many other cases of fugitives being
captured and enslaved by Indians many
tribes kept slaves the Cherokees frankly
saw slavery adopting Anglo style slavery
as part of becoming civilized you know
becoming an assimilated part of you know
American culture I tried my might in
fact he'll kill a fugitive might send
him back might sell him there's no one
consistent story it really depict varied
from depending on the place and time you
asked about central New York State I
have personally not come across any
actions on the part of the Onondaga is
related to the Underground Railroad
although they're sitting there right on
the edges here accuse and it's very very
possible but I've seen no evidence of it
in further western New York State there
is some documentary evidence of Seneca
Indians being involved in the
Underground I haven't written about it
in the book but I've woven made
Americans in here and there sure hi well
I was just in Cincinnati two weeks ago
at the Freedom Center as they generally
call it it's brand-new it's beautiful
it's on the banks of the Ohio River it's
called the National Underground Railroad
Freedom Center just opened last August
with a wonderful director named Spencer
crew who formerly was the director of
the National Museum of American history
here in Washington and it's it is a new
museum that's to say it will do a lot
more as time goes on it has a wide
variety of exhibits I'm kind of kind of
the old school I like objects I like to
go to a museum it's the old things and
there are displays there that I just
there were riveting for me they had you
know John John Brown's the Rope that
John Brown was hang with his pistol you
know some of his things and this is it's
the real stuff and I'm very moved by
things like that
but there are also some extremely fine
high tech sections for a surround sound
theater with a very finely produced film
that tries to put you in the shoes of a
fugitive and his wife attempting to
escape across the Ohio from Kentucky to
all to a heart to the state of Ohio to
Ripley
well there may there may be but the
Underground Railroad
generally speaking wasn't something that
generated artifacts which is one of the
problems that the Freedom Center had in
kind of creating the displays that we
used to seeing in museums which is to
say fugitives themselves didn't bring
much with them and what they brought
they wore or ate basically or spent they
had money they didn't bring family
heirlooms and there are I mean there
were certainly where there are houses
that were safe houses where families
they're known to have been involved in
the underground lived as in Ripley Ohio
Madison Indiana a few others certainly
there are more places I think to be
identified and found and happily there's
a multitude of researchers today kind of
ferreting out these sites well I suppose
in my mind what social movements can
best learn is from the moral courage of
the people who participated the sphere
of organization isn't really my milieu
okay but it is true these folks are
great-great-great-grandparents build a
movement that really worked it succeeded
they organized an aggressive route sway
magnificently spanning more than a dozen
states but you know I think this is in
my in my own view in our political life
today I don't see a super abundance of
moral courage and I certainly don't see
it I certainly don't see it in dealing
with the consequences of slavery in this
country and and the much broader issues
bearing on poverty in the United States
today which transcends the color line
frankly I we seem to live in an era when
people which assume that this will kind
of solve itself I don't
happened to believe that and and I I
think that you know by looking at the
ability of people whether it's Georgia
Baptist or David Ruggles or Levi coffin
the the the way in which these folks are
able to choose year after year to make
this kind of moral commitment to
something that was really difficult and
indeed to work and sacrifice on behalf
of people there might not even be
comfortable with and I think for a real
social movement to work that the the the
basis of the criterion shouldn't be a my
real you know do I really want to sit
around and have a beer with with these
guys or do I want to do what needs to be
done you know regardless of what the
issue is so I do think their lives offer
a lot of a lot of fodder for our for our
hearts and minds right hi I was doing
some genealogy few years back in
Northwest Pennsylvania and found some
relatives have been active stationmaster
and it seemed to suggest also that
slaves at times Oh at times although I
think it's one of them's in the front of
the book here in fact bound for Canaan
is taken from from a song which
Frederick Douglass quotes in his
autobiography and which I will spare
everyone my rendering of since I was
when I was in the high school choir has
told to meld the words but but but I'll
just read you know these couple of lines
here which Douglass quotes okay none
sweet cane and I'm bound for the land of
Canaan and Douglass writes we were at
times remarkably buoyant singing hymns
and making joyous exclamations almost as
triumphant in their tone as if we had
reached a land of freedom and safety
when we sang these it was something more
than a hope of reaching heaven we meant
to reach the North and the North was our
Canaan so but I think when talking about
the Underground Railroad it's really
necessary to be cautious and not
extrapolate a local instance into a
sorry you
Universal truth about the Underground
Railroad in other words because this
song was sung on the the Eastern Shore
of Maryland when Frederick Douglass was
enslaved there doesn't mean that
everybody everywhere in the South sang
this song as a code you know and
similarly because a certain certain
farmer in southern southern Indiana had
had created a hidden hiding place behind
his his a false chimney in fact it
doesn't mean that every time you find an
exotic hiding place in an old house you
know it was an underground railroad
hiding place and there's this tendency I
think you know to kind of assume that
what was true in one place was true kind
of universally and the Underground
Railroad was as diverse as the people in
it basically your hand was almost up I
see it going up if the Civil War helped
her birthday on the ground
because it seemed to take another
hundred years for the civil rights
movement to come forth and you know why
did it take so long how come they didn't
spark the revolution after a great more
like that and so maybe a hurt rather
than help
well I at the end of the book I sort of
I bring the book right up into the Civil
War and Arnold Gregston was still
ferrying fugitives across the ohio i was
late as 1863 basically as Union armies
moved south during the war the
Underground Railroad became a vast
highway and and plantations hemorrhaged
slaves who who made made made headway
behind the Union lines hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of people and
slavery collapsed William Tecumseh
Sherman marched through Georgia was
frankly a real racist and he possibly
might have owned a slave at one point in
his life as an officer but he liberated
more slaves than any other single person
in American history but I want to answer
your question was a bit different so yes
the war put an end to the Underground
Railroad because it ceased to be
necessary but what happened why did it
take another hundred years is because
african-americans were betrayed in the
1870s by the North abandoning
reconstruction abandoning aggressive
reconstruction and enabling power
structures in the south to reassert
themselves and to re-establish you know
a a kind of semi slavery as an economic
political and social regime for the
south and the country turned its backs
on african-americans frankly I mean it's
it was it was it's simple and terrible
wait a minute
why did we fight each other and do all
of this and so it kind of retracts from
it because that's another hundred years
it took you know segregation and
suffering and certainly detracting from
the generations that followed that's
true get a kind of a simulated bye-bye
you know by numbers over time rather
than to me
well that that that actually was the
argument that that what I would call
genteel defenders of slavery made in
antebellum time say well it'll work
itself out naturally but in there were 1
million slaves in the 1800 there were 4
million in 1860 the number of slaves was
increasing exponentially
not through importation that was ended
in 1808 as well by natural birth and
slavery was radically increasing and
becoming more powerful it was not on the
decline and you know it was you know our
founding fathers failed to deal in a
creative way with this in 1787 with the
you know establishment of the country
they postponed it and they knew they
were postponing it they knew exactly
what they were postponing and they hoped
it would work itself out you know I
think a lot of you know the generation
that followed the Underground Railroad
geneviève generation lacked the kind of
moral courage that its parents that have
I think I think there was another camp
yes
a particular spot no but but yeah well
Dayton there was a lot of underground
activity around Dayton and and
Cincinnati it was an intense area of
activity in two directions north to
south and west to east very significant
a lot of church people from different
denominations participated in the
Underground Railroad over time but no
Church as a whole committed itself to
the Underground Railroad or abolitionism
the Quakers come closest but all the
churches divided over it and of course
the the the main Protestant churches
divided geographically between north and
south congregations in the North divided
and up in central New York State
anti-slavery people radicals that's to
say Underground Railroad people really
in the Presbyterian and Congregational
churches actually formed separate
congregations which for a period were
called preservationist because they were
defined by their political commitment
rather than their their congregation I
think maybe it's a weak okay yeah I want
to say again if anybody wants to leave
but don't be shy you know it's okay but
but we'd like to have a book sign did
don't hesitate and just just come up and
I can do it while we're still talking
but I'm happy to take more questions
Thanks you're so patient thank you thank
you
I know you use